[Music]
since the original How to Train Your
Dragon fans fell in love with the
misunderstood toothless the trailer for
the third movie in the series have
ramped up anticipation as a female and
potential love interest is introduced
watch until number one to see why we
think the trailer is trying to mislead
us if this is your first time visiting
the things don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
here's ten things that don't make any
sense and How to Train Your Dragon 3 the
hidden world flirting lessons one of the
main elements of How to Train Your
Dragon the hidden world trailer that
caught audiences has to do with the new
courtship between toothless and a female
dragon we can already see that hiccup
does his best to coach toothless when it
comes to flirting
however toothless is apparent lack of
any type of knowledge related to how to
flirt doesn't really make any sense
light fury as she is being called is
considered to be a wild and elusive
dragon who is afraid of humans oh sorry
toothless on the other hand considers
humans to be his family he also seems to
be instantly attracted to her based
solely on the fact that they look like
they're the same species an article from
Nerdist suggests that toothless is lack
of game has to do with the fact that he
doesn't have a family that would have
taught him these subtle social
interactions
hiccup isn't very helpful either but
that's because he's too closely
connected to toothless and doesn't want
to see him grow up and go away not only
are these statements contradictory but
by this time wouldn't have toothless
been affected by steen other dragons
around him not to mention hiccup and
Astrid it doesn't make sense that hiccup
is this clueless about flirting stoic is
back there's no questioning stoic as a
great memorable character and a
wonderful dad I'm trying
to call you my son voiced by Gerard
Butler he's left a lasting impression on
audiences spoiler alert if you haven't
seen the second movie but it would be
safe to assume that most audiences would
not be looking for stoic in the third
and large installment of the How to
Train Your Dragon series yaki makes an
appearance though this doesn't make
sense
we can maybe entertain possible theories
that would make Stoics comeback possible
in How to Train Your Dragon the hidden
world a movie web article suggests that
stoic could be part of some kind of
dream sequence in the movie though this
would explain the confirmation of Butler
as a member of the movies cast it still
seems like a small detail to have
included in the trailer as it would have
been a fun surprise reserved for just a
scene of the movie in an interview with
Screen Rant
Butler has said that he believes this
movie to be the third and final chapter
the series deserves adding that he is
confident fans won't be disappointed
maybe we will just have to wait to see
how stoic makes it back into the hidden
world but one thing's for sure we're
happy he'll be a part of it underground
world as a title the hidden world is
cool because it suggests the discovery
of something new and exciting it wasn't
until the trailer was released that it
became clear that it also alludes to an
important setting for the movie the
trailer is study revealing an
underground world full of dragons
there's a lot of light and glowing - as
well as cave-like structures that extend
overhead there seemed to be Everest moss
and emerald like stones jetting out of
the ground there are also bright neon
coral reef type plants in the background
of the poster the post published by big
eyes on a net cool compares the studying
of this underground hidden world to a
psychedelic forest like something out of
a vut R or the Dwemer underground
village from Skyrim it's definitely
visually appealing and suggests a
mythical or magical elements that should
be very interesting the main issue with
this literal hidden world is that it
doesn't make sense in the context of the
story as presented in the trailer we are
told that the Dragons will have to be
protected by the humans
we're having trouble wondering how
hiding them in the hidden world isn't
the obvious solution to this problem
hiccups beard one character whom we are
excited to see back
action in How to Train Your Dragon the
hidden world is hiccup voiced by Jay
Baruchel hiccups journey allowed him to
find his own place in his village
ultimately following his father's
footsteps and becoming a leader while
also forging his own path through his
friendship with toothless hiccup was
able to combine human and dragon
strength to create a utopia this is an
inspiring story that shows us the
benefit of remaining open-minded and
inclusive to those we classify as scary
just because they are different that's a
lot of wisdom to acquire for one
character in the trailer hiccup appears
beard and the internet ate it up that
only does the facial hair suit the
character but it is reminiscent of his
father's much larger beard it also
bestows Authority and reflects hiccups
wisdom all of which he has worked hard
to earn in the previous two movies
however one thing that doesn't make
sense about the beard is that it isn't
consistent throughout the whole trailer
this could signify a time gap or maybe
something happens that causes took up to
shave his beard let us know if you have
any predictions Night Fury or a light
Fury in the trailer Astrid refers to the
discovery of another dragon up toothless
as kind as a light Fury she's on great
fury however this is a bit confusing
since she seems to have the exact same
features as toothless except for her
color which would mean she is also a
Night Fury writer and director Dean
Dubois caused light fury an agent of
change
drawing toothless away from human
influence light fury is also described
as a close variation of toothless a
species light fairies ability to
disappear is brought up in the trailer
suggesting that though she might be a
similar species to toothless
she possesses different abilities even
like Furies physical characteristics
don't make any sense for one thing she
is sparkly has smaller nails hardly any
definition and appears to have smooth
skin instead of scaly skin
we haven't been presented with any
dragons in the franchise that appear to
be definitely male or female based on
their appearance - the choice to make
light fury so obviously feminine is
confusing this can actually be seen as
sexist as pointed out in an article from
The Daily Dot we're definitely excited
to see how this relationship turns out
and if any of these confusing
are addressed the villain let's talk
baddies for a second after all there
isn't much of a story to be told without
a compelling conflict F Murray Abraham
promises to deliver a tense performance
as the new villain grimille head of
DreamWorks Animation film group has
commented on this casting choice saying
that Abraham will bring an eerie
gentleman my calmness to the villain
Gribble is a big-game hunter who has
hunted night Furies into near extinction
and seeks to capture toothless to become
his hunting trophy and remover I will
never give him up Dubois said that
grimille is the perfect villain because
he's the perfect balance against
goodness he knows exactly what he wants
and is very single-minded in his
approach he's representative of a close
minded colonial approach whereby the
only good dragon is a dead dragon as
Dubois explains in an interview with
slash film one thing that doesn't make
sense is that we know that toothless and
light fury will have to work together to
prevent from being captured this seems
like a villain only threatening one of
the characters of the movie I'll be it
one of our favorites and yet it is
presented as an issue threatening all
dragons so far this conflict it doesn't
make any sense but we're sure things
will be clarified in the movie bird
mating tactics one thing that doesn't
make sense though it's adorable and
hilarious is the mating ritual we see in
the trailer for How to Train Your Dragon
the hidden world from what we can tell
dragons mate by using some sort of
mating dance
toothless seems to be completely unaware
of this but is encouraged to keep up his
hard work and determination by hiccup
who is watching from the sidelines this
doesn't make any sense
if toothless was so attracted to light
fury because she's one of his kind when
he thought he was the last he should
have already known how to mate with her
because they are from the same more
closely related species if light fury
was also awkward and unsure of what to
do toothless is adorable missteps would
make sense however we don't have any
other indication that she has interacted
with others of her species and she
somehow understands what to expect from
the mating ritual all of this is
reinforced by the fact that the BLA
researched bird mating rituals to help
understand or predict how dragons might
mate in an interview with Khalid er the
blah' also admits
used birds as inspiration because they
were the funniest Game of Thrones
similarities Vikings and fantastical
medieval Knights are not the same right
we've been second-guessing this since
the undeniable similarities between How
to Train Your Dragon the hidden world
trailer and shots from Game of Thrones
have been compared memes comparing the
two have always been popular for their
uncanny similarities now with the
inclusion of a white dragon and burning
ships as well as hiccups beard the
similarities are overwhelming it doesn't
make sense that there are so many
replicated images that often appear as
an animated representation of the
popular TV series even Kit Harington
voices a character in the movie you'd
make a good trapper a Huffington Post
article provides several examples of
resemblances between the two and it's
blowing our minds among the Pixar
toothless flying into battle in a stormy
sky compared to of Assyrian flying into
battle one last coincidence is Ed
Sheeran's cameo in Game of Thrones and
his song in the trailer for How to Train
Your Dragon the hidden world these
coincidences are mind-blowing and
unexplained they just don't make any
sense this prompts us to wonder if
writer and director Dean Dubois drew
some inspiration from some of the shots
in Game of Thrones whatever the origin
these epic shots are definitely getting
fans excited for the movie production
delay it's a good thing that absence
makes the heart grow fonder because we
have been waiting for a third How to
Train Your Dragon movie for a long time
apparently the delay is due in part to
the fact that DreamWorks has
restructured for a three films a year
plan still this doesn't explain the five
years between the second and third
installment of this very successful
series a lot of this has to do with the
movies being passed around the original
movie was released under DreamWorks
Animation's partnership with Paramount
Pictures the sequel was then a result of
a partnership between DreamWorks
Animation and 20th Century Fox now
produced by Universal that houses
DreamWorks Animation's
the third movie took time it is
understood that this is due to
DreamWorks Animation's financial
struggles over the course of the past
few years How to Train Your Dragon 3 is
also not the only movie that's been
delayed and is not the worst case
scenario
movies like monkeys of Mumbai Bo Oh
Bureau of outer worldly operatives and
me and my shadow are still in limbo and
awaiting release dates hopefully the
delay will be worth it even though it
means that How to Train Your Dragon the
hidden world will be opening the same
month as Captain Marvel and Godzilla two
sisters so let us get this straight
toothless finds another dragon that is
the same species as him he previously
believed he was the last of species yet
upon meeting flight fury his reaction is
to fall in love with her and not to
commence tracing their genealogy let's
step back and consider that even the
original synopsis of the movie stated
that toothless is elusive mate could
tempt him to leave there's no
confirmation that toothless and light
fury engage in a romantic relationship
and toothless leaving the strong bond he
has with hiccup for a love interest just
doesn't make sense to us based on the
fact that light fury looks like a female
left toothless rather than a dragon from
a similar species it's plausible they're
related the use of black and white for
each dragon can also serve as
confirmation that these two are not only
from the same species but from the same
family
now that star wars is Disney's property
and with examples like Elsa and Anna
where color is used as a way to
juxtapose siblings it's likely that the
trailer is meant to confuse us because
in reality toothless and light fury are
related what do you think let us know
your predictions in the comments and
that's all for 10 things that don't make
sense and How to Train Your Dragon 3 the
hidden world if this is your first time
visiting the things don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up
[Music]